hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for some
more Jojo talked quite specifically in
regards to my thoughts on part 4 Diamond
is unbreakable and I thought I'd do this
because pretty much every second comment
on the video discussing parts 1 through
3 was singing the praises of part 4 and
5 to no end and well in the case of
Diamond is unbreakable I have to say
that well you were all pretty damn
correct I think part 4 is extremely
solid in almost every single way
effectively addressing all of my major
complaints about Stardust Crusaders by
once again radically changing the format
of the series Diamond is unbreakable
adopts a more slice-of-life style of
storytelling which works super super
well with Iraqis desire to maintain a
sort of stand of the weak idea and the
reason why that didn't work for me so
much in part 3 is because the stakes
were so damn high right from the get-go
Jotaro and the gang were on a
time-sensitive mission to defeat the
ultimate evil do dude or else Holly was
going to die that was the overtone of
the entire series so getting bogged down
in monster-of-the-week stuff as well as
just general shenanigans of the main
cast always felt at odds with the tone
that part 3 had set up but in part 4 no
problems whatsoever because the slice of
life genre allows your shorter stories
to be more casual and not necessarily
feel like they need to contribute to a
greater narrative for example I think
one of the episodes that I had the most
fun in was when josuke and o kiasu went
to Tanya's restaurant for the first time
and the entire story was just
experimenting with the idea of mixing a
stand with food as well as some
villainous misdirection but it really
was a nice chillaxed experience whereas
if an episode like this were to
appearance starters Crusaders I would
have come out of it thinking that it was
a massive waste of time because we
really cannot afford to be taking
detours like that but detours really is
the name of the game and diamond is
unbreakable
and it just works so much better and
there was never a time where I was not
happy to go along with whatever crazy
event was happening be a dramatic
comedic or just plain weird there's a
there's a lot of just plain weird but
moving to our new protagonist I
generally like Joe skate quite a lot he
had a lot more personality equipped in
the quiet Jotaro or the rather stiff
Jonathan so it harks back to more of a
young joseph joestar kind of feel which
I really appreciate about him he has an
incredible set of quirks the most potent
of which being his sensitivity in
regards to his hair which even comes to
be nicely dramatically expanded upon and
after that moment even I got sensitive
about Joe's kiss her if anybody insults
that we are taking
outside the one thing I really wish we
had gotten more of though is josuke for
the protagonist of part 4 I'd say he
really didn't feel like the main
character for roughly half the series
quite often individuals like Koichi or
Rohan would take the home for episodes
and episodes on end which I didn't mind
because I loved the ensemble feel of
part 4 and I especially enjoyed those
two characters but josuke
I think is the least invested Jojo so
far he was just sort of around for these
events to be occurring like going back
Jonathan was tied directly to dear
Joseph to The Pillowman
and Jotaro to the task of saving his
mother's life meanwhile josuke just
happens to be a kid with a stand and all
sorts of crazy crap happening around him
with no profound driving force to really
act in the series which once again is
completely fine because the
slice-of-life business means that we can
spend time with josuke just screwing
around
but in stark contrast the episode
centering on Koichi and Rohan
specifically always felt like they held
a lot more dramatic umph at least for me
I do love josuke stand they're crazy
Dimond the moment I first saw it I knew
we were in for some insanity and it's
just so hard to predict what that thing
will be capable of in terms of sheer
creativity what I will say is that it
did sometimes undercut a lot of the
drama though because if somebody other
than josuke got hurt even mortally
wounded then there was almost never a
sense in my mind of oh damn like there
has been in every other part so far
because well crazy Dimond is just going
to fix everything right and for the most
part that was right
still I think losing that feeling was
very much worth it to explore this
amazingly cool stand in fact most of the
stands in part 4 were actually
outstanding I actually struggled to
think of one that I didn't enjoy I mean
if I had to choose then maybe the rat
stand was a bit basic but even then it
was used nicely in an episode where
Jotaro
the hero of the world is convincingly
defeated by said rat you know this is
the man who ultimately defeated do
brought to the verge of death by a
slightly above-average intelligent
rodent which I think officially makes
rat by far the most powerful figure in
Jojo to this point still every stand has
some wonderfully interesting abilities
that are starting to border on weird and
niche which I love because the super
basic stands apart 3 really didn't do it
for me at all but for the most part
anyway there were some great ones mostly
not however things like harvests the
lock and Super Fly are all kinds of
weird strange but incredibly potent and
hold a ton of fun use if implemented
creatively kind of like a nano bill
he's generally treated in Honda Honda
and yes I'm very much starting to see
how Jojo would have profoundly inspired
Takashi in regards to that but something
else I really loved about pot fall was
the setting Mario is a strange strange
town unlike anything I have ever seen
portrayed in the medium of animation
before and I was especially taken in by
the color palette of it actually because
seriously anything that can make a shot
dominated by baby [ __ ] Brown into an
aesthetically appealing setting is pure
genius part four really has very much
expanded my thoughts on color theory
that's for sure there was a lot to get
invested into here as well as the time
to actually do so as well
unlike the first three parts which are
marked by near consistent travel you
never get to really know a location like
we do with Mario and I think I'm going
to very much miss this little town going
forward plus it also introduced some new
concepts at least to me in the judge of
us like ghosts in the form of Raimi and
Arnold a dog in the series who yes does
die but is one of the very rare canines
to achieve a sense of revenge for its
murder which was quite satisfying to see
and it was very nice to have a layer
like this introduced there because I
think things do risk becoming a bit
stale if every single thing happens to
be explained by a stand also aliens
Meireles the possibility of aliens with
mickey taka I'm both heavily intrigued
and highly annoyed that that was never
explored further because yeah this is
one of those things that could probably
be explained by a stand but at the same
time aliens in the Georgia verse would
be something that I would be very
interested in something I was slightly
disappointed in was how Joseph was used
in part for Thoreau rather not used I
was really excited when I found out that
he was arriving in Moria and even if he
was somewhat old and senile I was hoping
that he would actually be relevant in
some way shape or form but in the end
all he really did was become involved
with the invisible baby which I'm going
to assume is important in future parts
sort of like the baby popping up in the
end of part 1 because otherwise I spent
an awful lot of time bringing the old
man here and focusing on an invisible
baby for no real reason now moving on to
something very important that I haven't
touched on yet yoshikawa Kyra hands down
the best Jo Jo antagonist thus far I
mean don't get me wrong I love deer but
he has a really flat sense of evil for
the sake of evil that never really
captivated me but Kyra is a legitimately
intriguing figure who doesn't want
anything so grand as to take over the
world but instead he just wants to live
a relatively quiet life
noticed by the world and is a highly
introverted individual which is a
feeling that I can heavily identify with
I mean less so the murdery hand fetish
but that's something else that made him
weird like disgustingly intriguing so to
bring up do again as a comparison
nothing he ever did really shocked me
because I knew he was just a prick for
the sake of being a prick but Kira was
capable of shocking me on many occasions
one of which was when he was licking the
fingers of the severed hand in public
which actually made me yell out a string
of no no no no no no so allowed that my
wife came in and asked what was wrong
but my favorite thing about Kira is that
he is a very rare breed of antagonist
who doesn't take action unless he
absolutely needs to and I do enjoy that
feeling of knowing that Kira will never
do anything unnecessary and watching him
become consistently cornered forcing him
to act once more and dig himself further
and further deeper into hell which
speaking of the poetic justice of Kira
being taken away by a legion of hands
was not lost on me although I'm actually
surprised at courage and just willingly
give himself up to the hundreds of hands
that appeared before him because surely
to Kira that would just be a harem of
hands for all eternity
heavenly even and as for the family that
Kira I guess adopts I was also surprised
at how much I became attached to Hayatou
because usually child characters just
annoy the hell out of me but there was
some very nice heart and soul put into
this kid and having him become a major
part of the series climax was a very
strong narrative move in my opinion
although there was one thing about the
final conflict that like really really
pissed me off which was when josuke and
O kiasu were facing off against Kira and
not like ten metres down the road was
standing Koichi Rohan and Jotaro just
completely oblivious to the action that
was going on right next to them despite
there being multiple explosions and
screams and at one stage Jotaro like
thinks he notices something then he
shrugs it off as I guess it was just the
sound of the rain despite the fact that
it had long since stopped raining at
this point but more importantly Jotaro
is the kind of man who is supposed to be
paranoid about every little thing I mean
this is the man who warned josuke not to
drink any water just on the old
possibility that the enemy stand might
be related in some way to water he
thinks about every possible scenario and
in this case he just goes well I guess
that thing was actually nothing which I
don't buy and that part was kind of
infuriating what I do buy very much
though is that fantastic ending which
was a bit of a shock the first time I
saw it because the music began and I was
listening and then ice
to myself this sounds a lot like Savage
Garden and then the voice of Darren
Hayes began singing and just yeah that's
insane
so basically an Australian 90s pop song
was certainly not what I was expecting
from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure but hey if
its mission was to invoke a sense of the
90s then it sure as hell worked for me
because I was listening to that exact
song in the 90s so nostalgia all over
they also really enjoyed that it was
effectively one tracking shot straight
through Moria highlighting all of the
characters that we'd met and even hiding
some in some very sneaky places although
I was really hoping that after every
news story the character characters we'd
met would be added in for us to find but
instead they seemed to add the
characters in and giant batches which
you know is also cool I guess because
it's a generally fun ending so overall
diamond is unbreakable was a hugely
enjoyable experience on par with part
two if not better for me it is difficult
to compare it with battle tendency
though because the genres are so
radically different I mean if I had to
choose and maybe I'd say part four
because we got to spend more time in
such a great environment then again part
2 told its story so wonderfully and
efficiently in a short amount of time so
you cannot fault it for that no no no
we'll see maybe I'll watch part 5 and
this will all become a moot point
because that will be so damn good and I
honestly have no idea what to expect
from this series at the moment every
part is almost like a completely
different world which means that
starting a new part is always going to
be a gamble especially when you found
the last part so enjoyable so in any
case it is now time for golden wind and
that pretty much does it for my thoughts
on part 4 of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produce in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my desk
or server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on Diamond is unbreakable this
has been the new old review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]